déambuler dans la ville pour découvrir
rambouillet sous l'occupation
c'est le thème des visites de cette
ville d'art et d'histoire le lieu de
départ le palais du roi de rome un lieu
emblématique pour commencer la visite
qui dure environ 1h30 on connaît jamais
vraiment complètement sa ville et donc
ça peut permettre de te découvrir des
nouveaux endroits et il connaître des
événements qui se sont produits sur
suran briel des cas une visite nouvelles
sur c'est sur ces thèmes d'histoire de
rambouillet histoire très riche de
rambouillet détiennent visite nouvelle
qui est proposé on essaye de participer
direction l'église saint lubin rue
gambetta pour ce groupe de neuf curieux
une visite pleine d'anecdotes qui permet
aux romoli temps de se familiariser avec
leur histoire et faire leur devoir de
mémoire
cette première visite en fait elle est
un peu solide parce que c'est la
première fois qu'on l'a fait donc
j'espère qu'à plaira et en fait c'est
voir rambouillet sous un autre angle
c'est le plus calmement le plus
contemporain aussi si je puis dire début
xxème siècle voilà rambouillet cette
période de l'occupation qu'est ce qui
s'est passé comment rambouillet a été
marqué et surtout la période de la
libération même s'il s'appelle
rambouillet sous l'occupation
parce que rambouillet a été témoin en
fait événement hors du commun au niveau
de local mais aussi qu'ils rejoignent
l'histoire nationale et donc c'est
vraiment passionnant
pendant toute la visite le groupe
s'arrêtera devant le bureau de poste
l'école primaire gambetta une villa
occupée par l'armée américaine ou encore
l'emblématique gare et le château de
rambouillet tout en respectant les
règles sanitaires actuellement nous
avons des jauges encore très limité donc
aujourd'hui ces neuf personnes plus le
guide conférencier donc effectivement il
fallait réserver le masque est
obligatoire pour le public et après la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire on va
remonter un petit peu la jauge mais la
réservation restera prudente un des
visites tout public sur réservation qui
ont commencé en juillet et se
termineront en septembre pour les
prochaines déambulation les habitants
pourront découvrir rambouillet en tant
que ville impériale ou encore
rambouillet autant des présidents